In the US, the White House said the United States...
...has begun withdrawing troops from Syria,...
...shortly after President Donald Trump tweeted...
...the US has defeated the Islamic State terror group there.
Voters in Madagascar are casting ballots in a presidential runoff election...
...between two former presidents and bitter rivals,...
...Andry Rajoelina and Marc Ravalomanana.
In Britain, British Prime Minister Theresa May says...
...she is working with the EU to gain the assurances she believes are necessary...
...to win the support of Parliament,...
...after the EU set out its terms for a no-deal Brexit on Wednesday.
In China, a Chinese foreign ministry spokeswoman said...
...the United States should rethink its recent rhetoric on China-Africa cooperation.
US National Security Adviser John Bolton last week criticized China...
...for "expanding its influence" in Africa.
Finally from Turkey, crew members of a cargo ship were brought ashore...
.....using a zip line after heavy winds forced the vessel "Natalia"...
...to run aground off Istanbul's coastal Sile district.